Hey Travis, how are you?
Good. How are you doing?
I'm good too. How's everything going on your end?
It is busy, which is a good thing.
Okay, Crystal, gonna join?
I believe so. I was just, we were just on another meeting with the rest of the team, and I was saying we have another call to jump on, so it's time for us to leave. So she should be coming on here shortly.
Okay, Travis, I had a small query like we are going to see Agam's renewal and you said to you inform Vishal to connect with Dennis. Has your team hierarchy changed or?
Is Dennis taking off all taking care of all the renewals or something like that?
There's two different parts and I don't know where it flows. So Jolene was controlling the contracts. I don't think that's the right level. I don't think she's.
probably paying attention to the renewals of each of these. I think Dennis was holding the relationship in between the two companies as like the relationship owner and structuring everything back and forth. So the performance review will come to me and then I'll work with Crystal for that and then the strategic renewal portion of it.
I sent him to Dennis to see if he handles it or if it needs to go up to Jolene. If it needs to come back to me, it certainly can. But the original signing and negotiations and all that stuff, I think was with Dennis. I just don't know for sure.
Yeah, so because we so Jolene was from HR team, correct?
Yeah.
Okay.
So can you get us more clarity on that? Because if it goes to Dennis, he is actually taking care of the NOC side. So, and I guess Marco, the business is divided into two parts, correct?
Yep. Did Dennis send you back?
No, no, my Vishal is yet to connect with Dennis. I just wanted to know, like, how the things are and where should we move forward for discussions?
Okay.
I don't know, to be honest with you. Everything that I did ran through Dennis originally, and then I had to reach out to Jolene to sign. So I don't know where, if it lives with me, wonderful. I'll let somebody say, yep, go for it. And then I'll own it. And if they still want to own it, then I'll let them.
Yeah.
Okay, no worries. I'll let Vishal discuss with Dennis and see how the things go. Vishal, how are you?
Thank you.
I'm good, thank you. How are you?
Are you going good?
How's everything going on?
Been going well.
What about connector ways? What about connector ways?
Lots of process change.
Travis, did we get a date confirmed? Are they gonna let me do it June 15th?
No, somebody, I think I got a message last night about this, asking something.
I haven't responded to anything. We don't have a date for any of it yet.
Yeah.
Uh, or it was to see if we still had...
access to test and if it needs to be respun up and all that other stuff. So I got to see what updates are happening in ConnectWise prior to us re-engaging with test to see if they're going to reset all that crap again and then figure out what training looks like.
It's already done.
Test.
Yeah, I got Sarah reached out and got me back into it and then reactivated everybody along with the link for the email.
Okay, I got an invite last night at 830 to discuss this, so I'll update the rest of the team.
Okay.
So, no official date yet.
Oh, great. So, Crystal, how's your learning going on with Connectways?
We had a two-hour meeting yesterday, and because we haven't been in it, we got kicked out of the test. They did some updates, and we all got kicked out of it. So we got back in yesterday afternoon, and I was like, it looks familiar, but I don't remember where I'm touching or where I'm going or what this is. So.
Kip.
Kind of went backwards of, but we got some stuff actually written down, some steps. While I was touching buttons, one of the other team members was actually writing it down so that we can remember for next time. But it's going. It's more familiar, but
Yeah.
Still lots of questions for the team of actually doing it, taking one call at a time. And like, here's this roadblock. How are we going to manage it? Where do we go from here?
So, it's been interesting.
Okay, great. Travis, how's the journey for you?
Easy, I'm just waiting for them to do the cutover date.
Yeah.
Obviously, you don't have to work a lot on ConnectWise, correct? That's why.
Uh, I, I'm in Connectways every day, all day.
Okay.
Support.
Well, my other team coordinates all the installs and we're in ConnectWise. That's how our internal ticketing system is as well. So I'm in there looking up everything and making sure everybody else is doing what they're supposed to be doing already. So if another team joins me, that's just one platform instead of adding.
I help you.
the other two. A lot easier for me to assist if they're all on the same platform than breaking apart different ones.
Three G.
Yep.
But at the same time, I know Crystal's worried about it, so...
No worry. Hey, Crystal, it's, I would say, it's a good boat to sail. It's pretty easy.
I think it's a lot bigger than what we need. So there's a lot more things to do in it than what we're used to.
Kip.
Yeah.
Change is not easy, but change happens for good, I would say.
Kip.
We'll get used to it.
Okay.
Yeah, let me share the presentation. Nothing much. So, agenda stays the same updates, performance metrics, all the calendar, ITBD offerings, we forward in recap. And so, biweekly calls have been good. Crystal has been sharing.
positive feedback, we are seeing less errors with the new process coming in. There are challenges that the team is facing and they are discussing that. So the bi-weekly calls is a good format for the team to receive feedback and work on that. Okay, so that's all.
That's a great way of discussing one-on-one. So thanks, Crystal, for heading that. And for Adler, he has been progressing well. He has been taking good care of the work. He is getting confused because there are a lot of process changes that are happening on a regular basis.
Yeah, that's a bit confusing for him, but yes, he is progressing well through them. So last I was thinking like it would be done by May end, but yes, we still do not have a transition date. We already discussed that. Okay. Moving on next for performance metrics.
So April for Agam, 736 emails, one invoices invoice amount, 137.6 and call closed 10. Emails received for Adler 573, invoices 0 invoices amount 0 calls closed were four.
I just wanted to know like invoices amount, that's a new metric that has been introduced, Travis. Is that the total amount that is approved by the technician?
Yeah, that invoice amount may or may not actually be true. I might have copied that over wrong. But yeah, I've, it's a quantity of invoices and then the dollar amount they approve, and there's really nothing to the amount other than just a self-awareness thing.
Hey, I spent $10,000 on Marco's money last month.
Some people like it, some people don't really care.
Okay, so I'll remove this metric going forward because that's an internal metric. You shared and I thought like, oh, there's something new. I haven't seen this. Let's add that. Yeah, and I guess we still do not have a baseline because we are still preparing to migrate to ConnectWise. Once we have migrated to ConnectWise, we'll definitely see a better.
Sure.
Yeah.
Matrix, but that's still pending.
Moving on next to the holiday calendar. So no upcoming holidays for the month of May as of now. And upcoming holiday that's coming on 3rd July.
The one which we went to was 25th May and way forward like team is still using that OneNote. Crystal has a good.
part to update it regularly with the new processes and everything. Yeah, so the team is dedicating time in reading that and making sure that they are not making any misses. Obviously, we have seen like the misses are very less. Over to you, Crystal, a consolidate feedback, what do you see?
With the team.
Doing well. There's little misses here and there, which we're all human, I would expect that. Reminders of those processes, the little things.
The little things, they turn into big things if we're not being careful. So trying to make sure to reach out to the team when I see little misses, just so they know how I would handle them differently or anything like that. But overall, I think the team is doing well, even
with some of the process changes and...
and being frustrated, but they're doing well.
Yeah, definitely there is some frustration around the process changes happening frequently, but yeah, they are coping with it and they know like there's a time where they need to stay strong.
Travis.
Overall, good. And that's just an overall team measurement right there. We made some changes and...
Uh, how to how to best to say this: the right clicks changes to what's being entered, um, have changed around.
But the overall arching is to keep customers updated, so we have less work in the long run. I've been trying to stage all of this, so it's an easier transition to ConnectWise. So there won't be as many adjustments once we're in ConnectWise to what we're doing in today's world. So they're probably processing a little bit more in a strange format.
just so it's easier, right? Instead of entering notes here, enter them into this other place. So trying to strategically place all of as many changes as we can and it's just platform where we're entering them. So overall good though.
I don't think there's been anything that's caught my eye or attention of consistent misses or delays or anything like that so.
It's a good thing.
Great, great to hear.
Lee and Sameer are here.
You guys want to add on anything?
No, just dropping in to say hello. Hadn't seen you guys in a little while. Crystal, Travis, great to see you both. Sounds like there's a lot going on, as usual, as is the way in the space and at Marco. So hopefully everything continues to get smoother and smoother.
Yeah.
I'm glad to hear that there's nothing, that there aren't repeated issues and appreciative of the, you know, the feedback of the items where there are things to look at. But yeah, overall, glad to hear that things are stable.
Yeah, I think the only questions are expected off the changes that I've been pushing out, so I don't see any issues, just the learning curve again.
Sameer.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah.
Nice.
Sameer and Lee, I just wanted to apprise you. Like I just spoke with Travis, like has there been any leadership changes or anything? So he said like, he's not aware who would do that renewal since Dennis is our relationship manager.
And that's why he referred Dennis to talk to Dennis regarding the renewal for Agarwal.
Sure.
The performance review will come through us. I just don't know, right? The original agreement was signed by Jolene, but I don't know if she's going to be doing the renewal. So I think one step lower than that, I think it's still with Dennis. But if you guys hear differently, let me know and I can take care of it too.
Send me that.
Sure, Sameer, anything you would like to add?
No, I'm good. I think you covered well. And I have this almost same question which you covered again. So you threw the answer. I don't have anything else. And I'm glad and happy that most of the part these engineers are covering up. It's 10% tail and tail, which are process misses, but I'm pretty sure with you and your help, Shashank.
Yeah, that was...
They should be fine. One open-ended question to both Crystal and Travis, like, if you want to, like, if you want to extend one year with a gum again, would you be comfortable in doing so if, if like the risk comes back to you, right? How he has been in past one year with you guys? So just an open-ended question to both.
The.
I like Crystal go first.
Right.
Yeah, I would absolutely renew with Gagan. He's been great to the team, with the team and helping and yeah.
Awesome. Glad to hear that. And Travis. And again, not throwing you guys under the bus or any pressure. I just wanted to know so that I can go back because he's yet for his internal assessment and he want to grow more. So that's the idea why I'm asking it because he needs to go through some learning management portal.
Yep.
No, absolutely.
go through some tests, right? That's where this question is coming from.
Yeah, absolutely, I would renew as well. We have him taking care of one of our larger customers with some specialty print needs. He's been doing a good job with all of that. What I'm looking forward to is the change of ConnectWise so I can pull out, right? He's doing all these things specifically for this one customer, but we can't.
track individual efforts towards that in current systems. So I'm looking forward to being able to pull that out instead of, right, he answered 12 emails. Now here's actually all the work that went into it instead of emails and invoices. That stuff's driven me crazy for years, but.
Yeah.
No, I'm happy and glad to hear this that things are moving in the right direction and I'm happy that you want to renew it. Just that I wanted to check in the pulse here, like how he's been performing. I got to know good things always from Shashank and that's why me and Lee both were here just to see if it's...
We would renew.
Ketan.
Thanks.
He's telling us the right story, not not checking on him, but is this that guy right or not, right? So we both.
Okay.
Yeah.
Gotta keep, gotta keep them honest, you know.
Das right.
So these guys don't trust me.
I.
Kip.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay, I'm good. Over to you, Ashish Shashank again. It's all your show.
Yeah, I'm good. Crystal and Travis are happy. I'm happy.
Meet next one, then.
Yep, sounds good. Appreciate it.
Thanks, thanks, team. Have a great day.
Thanks, Arora.
Thanks everybody. Great deal. Cheers.
Bye.
Nikki.
Yeah, nice to see you.